downtown in Zimbabwe's Capital Harare is
where a lot of small businesses and
Street Traders operate and where
Shoppers look for bargains despite High
inflation and price increases
we've got the official exchange rate and
The Unofficial exchange rate
what has tended to happen over the past
few months is that prices have largely
been driven by The Unofficial exchange
attend its movement has also been quite
you know escalative and that is also
translated into you know process
collections
the government blames currency
speculators for the crash in the value
of the Zimbabwe dollar as well as
businesses using the black market to
price their goods here is my shopping
list and this is what I bought the
basics soap sugar flour cooking oil I've
spent 16 on these groceries let's go to
a bigger supermarket and find out how
much these same items will cost
this is what I bought the same groceries
for 31 from the store this is why many
zimbabwes prefer buying from informal
Traders
the US dollar is legal tender here most
people prefer using it another reason
why the local currency keeps losing
value
public sector workers are demanding
their salaries in U.S dollars and an
increase in allowances to cushion them
against inflation
you can't have prices increasing every
week you can't have incomes you know
diminishing every every week it's a
national security issue so we have to we
have a serious Paradigm ship and accept
that listen in the meantime because
because of serious issues or
environmental issues whether it's a
perceived risk lack of confidence we
have to actually put our best foot
forward as a country and use the US
dollar
to make ends meet people are now selling
goods from their cars mainly in US
Dollars the government recently directed
authorities to impose some duties and
taxes exclusively in local currency
hoping this would increase demand for
the Zimbabwe dollar right now there is
no guarantee the government intervention
is going to work harumatasa Al Jazeera
Harare